bianca as the calder fire intensifies
and approaches lake tahoe thousands in
that area are being ordered to evacuate
governor sisolak has also issued a state
of emergency as some in nevada are being
urged to prepare to evacuate hector
mejia is live in north las vegas
explaining how our local community is
helping out good morning hector
[Music]
hey there sherry well firefighters are
answering a call for help a task force
of local firefighters left for lake
tahoe last night a crew of 20
firefighters six of them from right here
in north las vegas are making the trip
up there and they'll be out there for
the next two weeks or so and it's been a
fierce battle against the caldorf fire
it's now more than
186 thousand acres and grown 40 thousand
acres since friday evacuation warnings
turned into orders monday for
communities around lake tahoe dozens of
teams as we've been telling you have
been there fighting the fire but it's
only 15 percent contained that's where
our local crews come in
personnel from north las vegas and clark
county hit the road for tahoe last night
they met up with the fire department to
pick up supplies and another fire truck
along the way the north las vegas fire
chief here says they'll serve in a
supporting role taking care of fire
structures in small towns while the fire
departments up there handle the wildland
firefighting and a lot of fire
departments there have been stretched
so thin so this will really provide some
relief we'll of course keep you updated
and let you know how our fire crews are
doing up there reporting live hector
mejia 8 news now